2021's mortal kombat had a long road to
production
but bankruptcy is a changing crew and
even a global pandemic couldn't stop the
film from coming out
from its gory r-rated content to its
unique director
this is everything you need to know
about the new movie
every big name property is getting
adapted into a major hollywood
blockbuster these days
even video game movies long seen as
guaranteed box office bombs
are starting to deliver hits like sonic
the hedgehog given this phenomenon it's
easy to figure out what the 2021 reboot
of mortal kombat came from
if a film adaptation of this video game
could deliver robust box office returns
back in 1995
surely an adaptation more faithful to
the source material
buoyed by decades of nostalgia could
score an even bigger hall
believe it or not the original mortal
kombat movies weren't supposed to end
with mortal kombat annihilation
initially there were plans for this take
on the mortal kombat mythos to span
three whole movies however it never got
off the ground
with modern day speculation indicating
that this was due to lackluster box
office grosses
and derisive fan response to
annihilation though there haven't been
reports of a script developed for this
mythical third mortal combat movie
threshold entertainment tried to build
up hype for it on occasion
however progress was non-existent on
this production
which left the franchise dormant for
decades fans of the original mortal
kombat movies were understandably
disappointed with this outcome
and the original movies cult following
suggests that could have been a sizeable
audience for further adventures in this
interpretation of the universe
however there's a silver lining to every
stormy cloud
the absence of an annihilation follow-up
did help pave the way for the modern day
reboot of the mortal kombat series
welcome you're here to compete in
mortal combat for decades warner
brothers has owned everything from dc
comics to the pre-1986 library of mgm
movies
but in 2009 the company added another
major roster of famous titles and
characters to their library of projects
when they bought the intellectual
properties of midway games this was the
outfit responsible for seminal video
games ranging from rampage to mortal
kombat despite leaving a massive
impact on the world of video games the
company faced extreme financial pressure
in the modern world
after some uncertainty over where they'd
land midway games and the entire mortal
kombat franchise wound up at warner
brothers
with a company paying just 33 million
dollars to indefinitely own these iconic
games
it's a fitting home for the franchise
given that the studio had at the time
recently absorbed new line cinema among
that movie studios dense library of
titles other two 1990s mortal kombat
movies
having already assimilated the mortal
kombat films warner brothers now
controls the entire mortal kombat
franchise
in the summer of 2010 interest in seeing
a new cinematic take on mortal kombat
was reignited by the release of a fan
film entitled mortal kombat rebirth
the project is the brainchild of
director kevin tanchirowan
who was suddenly on everyone's mind as a
potential director for a new mortal
kombat movie
turns out tantra rowan was also thinking
the same thing rebirth was meant to be a
test film to show warner brothers what
his mortal kombat movie could look like
tangier robin was hired in 2011 to
officially tackle a mortal kombat reboot
it was a big move for the filmmaker
whose feature-length directorial efforts
up to that point were fame and glee the
3d concert movie
with initial reports claiming that
filming would start in 2012
it looked like mortal kombat was going
full steam ahead
however this new take on mortal kombats
kept getting pushed into the future
eventually tantra rowan left the
production in
this left the mortal kombat reboot
without the director for a whopping
3 years james 1 and warner brothers have
developed a close relationship over the
years which led to one signing on to
produce a new mortal kombat film in
august 2015
just months after directing the
universal blockbuster furious 7.
the timing of this deal doesn't just
reflect one's close ties to warner
brothers but also signals the trajectory
of his career
furious 7 was a runaway success proving
one could expand beyond the horror genre
he was also now someone associated with
properly handling big budget action
movies
belonging to well-established franchises
one stayed on board this version of
mortal kombat as a producer during its
six years of production
while directing other films for warner
brothers including aquaman and malignant
you may not realize it but you've likely
been exposed to director simon mccoy's
work
having helmed countless commercials
including a memorable duracell star wars
ad
mccoy's visually distinct over has been
seen all over the world
but after years in this field mccoyd was
looking to move from directing
advertisements to helming feature-length
projects
that opportunity came when he was picked
to direct the mortal kombat reboot
mccoy's aforementioned star wars
commercial was apparently the project
that put him on the producer's radar
in terms of his mortal kombat approach
mccoy explained to comicbook.com in 2021
that
everything has to feel authentic it
doesn't feel like there's that veneer of
sort of special effects over everything
that for me is the ultimate sort of
fantasy of science fiction films as when
you really believe
after simon mccoy was brought on board
news on the mortal kombat movie was
quiet for years
however in july 2019 exciting
developments finally began to creep in
as the film's cast was assembled
joe teslin was the first cast member
announced followed by names like
macarthur brooks
and tadana buasano from there the cast
kept growing and the project when
shrouded in silence began to trumpet its
bold new actors
lewis tan who had previously been a
contender to play marvel heroes iron
fist and xiang chi
became one of the rare members of the
cast not playing someone familiar to
longtime fans of the franchise
tan portrays an original character named
cole young who serves as a film's
protagonist
when it came time to actually shoot the
new mortal kombat movie
director simon mccoyd and james 1 opted
to shoot the project in a territory
familiar to both of them
their native australia when filming
began in september 2019
it was revealed that the production was
engaging in principal photography in
south australia's adelaide studios
as adelaide has largely been a shooting
location for local australian fare
mortal kombat provided a big budget
departure from the norm
shooting in this location had a number
of benefits for the mortal kombat reboot
for one thing it brought the production
close to home for some of the movies
leading actors
additionally it helped to further
separate this new reboot from the pair
of 1990s mortal kombat films
the pair of live-action mortal kombat
movies from the 1990s deliver stories
that firmly fit within the parameters
of pg-13 filmmaking while this allows
each film to attract teenage audiences
it also means that the gruesome violence
that defines mortal kombat
is almost totally absent over the years
this became a bit of a punchline in
discussions of the original two films
as fans grappled with the quandary of
how something so crucial to the games
could be excluded
when it came time for a reboot fans
around the world hoped for something
more accurate
these fans got their wish as the new
mortal kombat movie is indeed rated r
it's a rating that director simon mccoy
was insistent upon when developing the
feature
in fact mccoy explained to cinemablend
the rules around
mpaa ratings aren't what a lot of people
think they are it's the amount of blood
it's amount of red
it's interpretation of how you go about
it we had a lot of discussions about
getting the balance right so there was
gore and there was blood and there were
fatalities
and there is gore blood and fatalities
keeping all of that red at the center of
this new movie
resulted in an mpaa rating that promises
all the gruesome carnage fans of this
franchise are familiar with
mortal kombat wrapped up shooting just
before the end of 2019
the film initially had plenty of time
between the end of shooting
and its original january 2021 release
date
however this schedule was put together
under normal circumstances
as mortal kombat entered post-production
in 2020
normal circumstances were soon hard to
come by by march 2020 the kovit 19
pandemic had
totally appended the entertainment
industry mortal kombat was no exception
while principal photography was finished
reshoots had yet to be completed when
the pandemic took hold
this was revealed in a tweet from mortal
kombat producer todd ghana
who divulged details on the holdup but
always planned for it and thought would
do it in much
the pandemic had other plans he won't
have a release date for the movie until
theaters reopen
same for trailer the pandemic clearly
had adverse effects on the production of
mortal kombat
however the overall impact would turn
out to be minimal at least compared to
other movies
mortal kombat managed to come out just
three months after its original release
date
which indicates the production was able
to resolve issues in a timely manner
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you